[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في مرحله من مراحل الحياه كنت امارس لعبه
الشطرنج ولعبه الشطرنج تتطلب تركيز عالي
وجهد
ذهني اللي كان يصير ان في الاوقات اللي ما
العب فيها كان ذهني او عقلي يستحضر لي
سيناريوهات مختلفه من اللعبه
هذا بسبب صفه موجوده فيني ويمكن موجوده
فيكم اللي هي التفكير
المفرط التفكير المفرط لما نفكر
فيه دائما النظره له سلبيه حتى اذا دخلنا
جوجل وكتبنا اوفرين غالبا بيعطينا و
اوفر ولكن مثل ما ان لكل شي له ايجابياته
وسلبياته فكرت ايش ممكن تكون الايجابيات
من التفكير
المفرد في في المرحله الجامعيه وردني
تساؤل ليش الحكمه دائما مرتبطه بالكبار في
السن ايش العوامل اصلا اللي تصنع الحكمه
فاستخلف ان في بعض العوامل منها عامل
الايمان لكن الايمان ما مرتبط بالعمر ممكن
انه نقوي ايماننا ونحن ب فتره شبابنا في
ايضا التجارب لكن فعليا التجارب اللي
نعيشها حاليا اكثر بكثير من التجارب اللي
كان يعيشوها اسلافنا من قبل وفي مرحله
الشباب بالذات نحن نعيش تجارب اكثر من اي
مرحله ثانيه العامل يمكن يحتاج وقت اللي
هو الخبره ولكن نفس الشي ممكن ان نسابق
الزمن ونكسب خبره اكثر بالاطلاع على خبرات
الاخرين
لذلك اذا كنا نفكر اكثر تفكير المفرط يعني
نقدر ان نتجاوز الوقت وبالتالي نكسب
الحكمه اسرع
في مره قرات ان الكتب اللي نقراها ما
تعطينا المعلومات ولكن هي تشكل كيف
افكارنا او تعلمنا كيف نحنا
نفكر زين كيف نطبق هذا الشي في البدايه
لازم نعرف كيف نوجه افكارنا بدل لا نقول
هذه مشكله نعتبر ان هذا تحدي على سبيل
المثال اذا كان شخص يسيء معاملتنا ما نفكر
ان ليش هذا الشخص يعني معاملتك ذاك وليش
هذاك ليش هو يتصرف بهذا التصرف ولكن فكر
ان هذا
تحدي لنا على اساس ان نصير اكثر حكمه
واكثر قوه فبالتالي نتعامل مع الوضع
بطريقه
افضل الموضوع الثاني
انه الممارسه في كل شيء تخلينا اقوى
ممارسه الرياضه تخلينا اقوى ممارسه الفنون
والرسم والتصوير تخلينا اقوى في هذه
الامور لذلك حتى ممارسه التفكير تخلينا
اخوى في مرحله من المراحل كنت يعني حتى لو
ما احصل مشاكلي الخاصه اروح وادور مشاكل
عند الاخرين فبالتالي افكر فيها واستخلص
يعني ايش الحلول هذا الشي حسيت انه ممكن
يخليك اقوى واقوى فلذلك ما لازم ننتظر
المشاكل تقي ولكن نستبق ونفكر
فيها بسالكم سؤال وخلونا
نعترف من فيكم لما تصير ل مشكله يكتمها
وتبقى في داخله بس
اوكي زين قبل سنوات قليله انا كنت برفع
يدي على هذا السؤال ولكن تغيرت الحين اللي
لاحظته ان لما نشارك مشاكلنا مع الاخرين
نحنا ما بس نفكر بعقل واحد ولكن نفكر
بعقول مختلفه تفكيرك انت بعقلك مهما كان
كثير ولكن يمكن اني يتمحور حول دائره
واحده فبالتالي ممكن انه يسببلك اشياء مث
الاكتئاب والتوتر لانك تشوف عليه او على
هذا بمنظور واحد التفكير بعقول مختلفه
يعطينا منظور مختلف للمواضيع فبالتالي
يكون الوضع اسهل واحسن لحل
المشاكل في النهايه نقدر نقول ان ممكن ان
نستبدل الجهد الذهني والنفسي اللي سبب
التفكير المفرط والاكتئاب الى حياه اكثر
تقبلا
واسترخاء شكرا
[تصفيق]
لكم ch